provide a brief update on the china
virus as well as our economic recovery
which is going really
very well as you probably have been
hearing
nearly 85 percent of jurisdictions all
across our country
are reporting a very steep decline in
cases
and that's despite the fact that we have
the number one testing program anywhere
in the world
we're up to almost 70 million tests far
beyond any other country
this week cases nationwide have declined
by six percent
the test positivity rate has fallen to
just six point five percent a 71 percent
reduction
from april and a 15 reduction from mid
july that's a big reduction
the hospitalization rate for the virus
has been reduced by half
since april and i urge everyone to apply
common sense mitigation we know that
and we are all doing that and i want to
thank the american people for
really doing such a great job the united
states has now administered over 70
million tests more than
all of the european union combined
if you combine all of europe it's less
than what we do
millions of point of care tests are
processed in less than 24 hours and many
in under 15 minutes
nearly 80 of all commercial lab test
results are now returned within three
days so we've gotten that number down
from about eight days to three days
and that's only in the longer term lab
cases
but we have many 15-minute tests we have
some five-minute tests
the turnaround time for federal surge
testing sites
is just two days so when you send them
out
despite the fact that you have a
delivery time which you can't do
anything about
uh it's all the way down to two days
it's a very substantial reduction great
job by the people that do it
we are focused on aggressively shielding
the highest risk
individuals those living in nursing
homes and long-term care facilities
are less than one percent of the us
population but account for nearly half
of all fatalities
that's an incredible thing so it's one
percent of the u.s population but they
account for
nearly half of the fatalities from the
china virus that's why
we have rushed nursing home funding
protective gear
and rapid testing equipment and we will
announce additional measures to protect
nursing home residents
in the coming days we've worked very
hard with nursing home
companies and also with the governor's
50
governors all around the united states
and
we have developed a very good
relationship with most of the governors
and i think for the most part they're
doing a really good job they focus very
heavily on nursing homes and when they
need equipment that they can't get
remember they're supposed to get it but
when they can't get we have tremendous
amounts of
equipment in stock thanks to
my administration's decisive action to
save american jobs we're currently
witnessing the fastest economic recovery
in american history and that's because
the foundation
that we set previously before the virus
came and
hit our shore uh the foundation was so
strong we had such a strong
foundation that we're recovering much
faster than anybody anticipated
it turns out that it will be a very very
strong v
and you'll see that in just a second so
retail spending has fully recovered and
is now
at an all time high
that's not all time for this month or
last month that's at an all-time high
and you see that with the chart
this was previous to the
the plague i call it the plague coming
into our land and
and really affected 188 we're dealing
with 188 countries
and if you see we've not only recovered
but we're at a much higher level than we
were even then that's an incredible
number that nobody thought would even be
possible
so we're currently witnessing the
fastest economic recovery
in american history that's an amazing
statement
so retail spending is great and now if
they would put up auto production has
surged
28 and that's your auto production which
is right there
so you'll see that that's now about even
to where it was and that was at an
all-time
record high and we're already even
and if you had a chart for used cars
you'd see that
a used car sales are setting a record
and that's great for production because
when the used cars are
practically not available they're very
very tight that means you're going to
make a lot of new cars so that number is
going to go up even beyond what it is
right now but that's a fantastic number
that's a number that's
the equivalent of where it was and that
was a record
so you see what's happening with respect
to the economy and the recovery and the
stock market is almost at an all-time
high
in fact nasdaq is at an all-time high
it's had 14 days where we broke the
record already over the last two months
so a lot of great things are happening
through the historic
relief package that i signed into law we
saved
over 50 million american jobs 50 million
american jobs
and the unemployment rate is rapidly
going down you see that you've seen that
and i think you'll see it
over the next two months and you'll have
a good report even prior to the election
you're gonna have a very good report i
think you're gonna have an incredible
gdp you're gonna have a tremendous
uh report on business and a lot of it's
gonna be
released which is very fortunate prior
to the election i think the democrats
are going out of their way to try and
do whatever they can to stop these kind
of numbers they don't like these kind of
numbers because they think it will hurt
them in the election i think
we all have to pull together and we have
to do the right job and we have to do
what's
what's good for the american people we
were unfairly
treated by china because they could have
stopped it
with that being said china has purchased
the most amount of corn
in history the last week they purchased
the
two largest days in the history of corn
purchase
and a massive amount of soybeans
also cattle so china's been buying a lot
of
a lot of things and they're doing that
to keep me happy but they're dreaming
about joe biden they would love to have
that happen but i don't think that's
going to happen
they are dreaming about him and so is
iran dreaming about joe and
so are numerous other countries they
dream about it because if that happens
they'll own
the united states and china i can tell
you specifically will own the united
states can't let that happen
if you remember china had the worst the
worst year they've had in 67 years prior
to the plague
coming to our shores and uh
we are now starting to do really well
we're going to have a very good third
quarter maybe a great third quarter
we're going to have an incredible next
year unless somebody comes up in
quadruples taxes which is what they're
talking about doing and also
regulations we've said we've done more
in terms of cutting regulations than
any administration in history by far
whether it was four years or eight years
or in one case more than eight years
we have in less than four years done
more
regulation cutting by far and we're
doing more as we
as we go some of it's statutory you can
only do it at a certain pace you have to
wait 90 days you have to wait 120 days
before you can take the next step
we have tremendous regulation cutting
coming
with that being said we're going to have
certain regulations to protect the
environment and also
safety small business optimism has come
surging back in june it was higher than
any month under the previous
administration think of that so small
business optimism
was higher than any month under the
previous administration and that is
while we're going through a pandemic a
worldwide pandemic
you have a number like that and when you
see the numbers that we quoted just now
as to
what's happening with uh cases and all
of the other hospitalization rates
a lot of tremendous things are happening
industrial production is increasing at
the fastest rate
ever recorded i mean think of these
numbers
i mean how does that happen industrial
production is
increasing at the fastest rate on record
which is ever recorded consumer spending
is expected to grow
at an astronomical rate this quarter so
we don't have the number yet but
it looks like it's going to be at an
astronomical rate
i want to say that i want college
football to come back
these are strong healthy incredible
people
these are people that want to play
football very badly
a great great talent quarterback trevor
lawrence called me on
two days ago spoke to him a couple of
times
he said sir i want to just tell you we
want it back we want to play and
he's an incredible quarterback as you
know from an incredible school
clemson and uh he's going to have a very
good future in the nfl he's got
everything he's got height
accuracy a strong arm and he's fast
other than that i guess he's got some
problems but he's got
he's got the whole package i watched him
uh last year running maybe he's
faster than the the faster than uh
the backs that we're guarding i i think
he's going to be great but he's just a
great young man i talked to him actually
for a long time they want to play
football
and he made the statement that he feels
he's safer on the field
he's safer on the field than he is out
you know outside of the field he feels
very safe and if you look
the sec the big 12 and the acc
are back they want to come back and i
think they're coming back
the big ten the pac-12 are not
and i wish they would come back and you
know i just want to say uh
sort of sad because i've been fighting
for football to come back
we're trying to help the nfl as long as
they stand for our national anthem as
long as they
honor our flag in our country if they
start kneeling i'm not going to be
helping them much that might come back
but i won't be watching
neither will a lot of other people i
think what the nba did was atrocious i
thought it was disgraceful the way they
kneeled
and their ratings are reflective of that
but i think football has to get smart
at the nfl to see what happens but if
they do it they learned their lesson i
thought two years ago
when people started not watching and
when people
really weren't going to the game so much
a lot of empty seats all of a sudden so
they're going to learn that lesson again
if they don't
wise up but i just want to say so trevor
lawrence great
and some of the the
great people sec big 12 acc i want to
thank them and i want to congratulate
them for coming back
i want to also mention that cnn had a
story that will they blame trump for
football in the swing states
what a dishonest or that is well they
blame me i'm the one that's
pushing them to come back so they want
to try and blame me so
them and i guess the new york times
reported one person there was one person
in the story one person said maybe it's
trump's fault
and i'm the one pushing him back so i'd
like to see college football come back
i'd like to see them come back proud and
strong
i was very impressed by trevor i was
very impressed by other people that
called me
players called me coaches call me coach
oh
you want to coach who's central casting
for a movie if you're
doing a movie you have to put coach yo
as the head because this guy is central
casting but
when you have guys like nick saban and
others calling for it to come
back they want it to come back and these
are
great athletes these are not people that
seem to be at all susceptible to
this horrible disease and they want to
play football
and we have great testing so you'll be
able to test and
when cnn and the new york times new york
times quoted one person
one person and i'm the one pushing so
we'll get it straight i'm the one
pushing for football to come back i
think if i wasn't pushing
you wouldn't have anything happening so
with that we'll take uh
we'll take a few questions steve please
thank you the
u.s effort to extend the iran arms
embargo at the u.n security council
fell apart yesterday when will you
trigger a snapback of sanctions on iran
well we knew what the vote was going to
be but we'll be doing a snap back
you'll be watching it next week yeah
you'll be watching it next week
president putin wants to hold a video
summit on this subject
are you wanting to do that probably not
no i think we want to wait till after
the election look iran wants me to lose
so badly
because if they do you know iran is a
whole different ball game right now
they haven't been sponsoring terror
because they don't have very much
money to sponsor terror and they know we
just captured
four iranian ships as you know and we
brought them into houston
they were going to venezuela they're not
supposed to be doing that iran would
love to have me
defeated if if i win which i hope to win
how can you not when you see numbers
like this both on the
virus and on the economy i mean we
should win we should all be
keep this incredible thing going and i
built it once and i'll build it again
i've already i think the hardest part is
done in terms of the economy
and that's with or without additional
funds from
nancy pelosi they should have put the
things in
whether you call it the care act or
phase one phase two phase three but they
didn't do that you know they
put it at the end things that they're
asking for that have nothing to do with
corona
that have everything to do with the
radical left politics
received letters from your postal
service
saying that those ballots for november
third might not make it in time
as president isn't it your
responsibility since this is your postal
service to meet this critical need
well we have a man in there for two
months he's a very talented man he's a
brilliant business person he's done
great he's a very nice man also
and he uh louis he is uh working very
hard
but as you know the democrats aren't
approving the proper funding for
postal and they're not approving the
proper funding for this ridiculous thing
that they want to do which is
all mail-in voting if universal you
could call it mail-in voting
again absentee voting is great you
request i'm an absentee voter because i
requested
i got and then i sent in my vote so that
works out very well that's what we've
had
but now they want to send in millions
and millions of ballots
and you see what's happening they're
being lost they're being discarded
they're finding them in piles it's going
to be a catastrophe
so and this is beyond the post office
but
louis de joy is is working very hard the
post office has for decades lost
billions and billions of dollars i read
numbers today that are unthinkable
and what they want to do now is hit the
post office with
millions of ballots from certain states
and if you look at what happened in new
york in virginia and various other
places it's a catastrophe they're losing
20 percent of the votes
nobody knows what's happened so
we're going to see what happens but i do
say this
universal mail-in voting is going to be
catastrophic it's going to make our
country a laughingstock all over the
world you can't
send out millions of ballots and look at
all of the tests like you've seen them
then there are many far more just look
at new york look at new jersey
look at the catastrophe in new jersey
and new jersey had more than just
patterson
look at what's going on in virginia look
at what's happening with this male in
voting it's a disgrace
absentee is good mail-in
universal is very very bad there's no
way they're going to get it accurately
they're off by 20 and 30 percent
and this is beyond post office now with
that being said
they want money for the universal
mail-in
uh ballots and they're not getting it
you know why because of them
we want money to go to people they want
money in order to bail out states that
have done very poorly
the states that have done poorly you
know them as well as i do
these are run by democrats usually
radical left democrats
you take a look at what's happening in
portland and we'll go into portland
we have to be asked we'll go into
portland straighten it out in one hour
like happened in minneapolis we'll go
straighten it out in one hour
we will straighten it out so fast but
they have to ask us
so they need money but they're not
willing to approve the money that they
need
if they can't get the money that they
need for universal
mail-in voting i don't see how they can
have it
and that's not only post office it's
also for the voting itself
does postmaster de joy have your backing
for the actions that he's taken in the
last several years
he's a fantastic man he wants to he
wants to make the post office great
again
you ever hear the expression he wants to
make the post office great again
the post office is a catastrophe male
sorting machines nationwide that's one
of them
i don't know i don't know what he's
doing i can only tell you he's a very
smart man
he'll be a great postmaster general and
he needs obviously if you're going to do
these millions of ballots out of nowhere
he's going to obviously need funding
but the democrats aren't willing to
provide other things and therefore
they're not going to get the funding for
that
but you are going to have a catastrophic
situation
with universal mail-in votes and on top
of it
the democrats aren't willing to give the
people the money and the post office the
money
the catastrophic situation is going to
happen but what are you doing to ensure
that that doesn't happen because
wouldn't these problems
raise questions about the election
results if you will
well the problem with the mail in voting
number one you're never going to know
when the election's over
okay i mean they called the election in
new york for carol and maloney they
shouldn't have done that i think you
should redo that election
and you know the opponent is screaming
they can't believe it
ballots are lost balanced or defrauded
it's a total mess
and they called it for her the reason is
because i've been using it as a case
i've been using it as a case so look
we are going to have an election that
takes place
on a beautiful day november 3rd and
usually at the end of the evening they
say
donald trump has won the election donald
trump is your new president
whatever they say you know what you're
not going to know this
possibly if you really did it right for
months or for years
because these ballots are all going to
be lost they're going to be gone
and just take a look at a smaller basis
but it's great tests we're doing tests i
mean
these are you could call them polls you
could call them tests
look at what's happening all over the
country where you have
universal mail wait a minute the ballots
are lost
there's fraud there's theft it's
it's happening all over the place now
we're going to do it with this whole
vast big section of the country it's
crazy
you have made it so plain that you are
opposed and do not trust
mail in voting is your postmaster
general using
the agency of the postal service to
create delays
no not at all he would love to see it
happen i didn't speak to him about it
but i will tell you this i would imagine
he would say
number one they didn't give me the
funding for it because it's sitting in
congress because they
they want a trillion dollars to bail out
states just so you understand what they
want they want a trillion dollars to
bail out badly run democrat-run states
okay that's what they want they're not
giving the money
to the post office they have to give the
money to the post office
are creating some delays now the steps
he's creating
to decide no not at all the steps that
he's taking
are trying to stop the tremendous losses
that have taken place for many many
years he's trying to streamline the post
office and make it
great again okay
look i just read last night that now new
jersey's going to try the
universal mail-in voting
well they didn't know this so now all of
a sudden new jersey's going to be hit
with millions of
ballots to be sent out they didn't know
anything about this
so how does a post office how does a
postal service
that doesn't know about it now all of a
sudden new jersey's supposed to take out
and millions of ballots are going to be
sent all over new jersey and if you look
at some of the things they say
like in take the state of
nevada take that little scam that's
going on over there with the
clubhouse politician governor take that
where the votes don't even have to be in
until seven they get counted seven days
after november third
that means if nevada is a very important
state i think we have a great chance of
winning that state
if the votes don't have to be in 4-7 and
they're not counting the votes
seven days later that means how are they
going to predict a winner on november
third
mr president
was automatically sent to somebody
no absentee is okay okay but once the
ballot gets into the mail
it doesn't matter but the workers have
to sort it so the bottom line is there
must be more resources
for post office but the democrats are
not they are not approving the resources
you're right there has to be more
resources i agree because all of a
sudden the post office is
tripling up and set the problem is the
democrats
are not approving the funds necessary
it's in there now they have 25 billion
i've seen 15 billion i've seen a lot of
money
i don't know how you're going to spend
that much but that's what they're saying
they're saying
so not only do they want a trillion
dollars to hand out as welfare to all
these states that are run by democrats
doing badly
they want 25 billion dollars for the
post office
but they're not approving it now what i
want is a lot of money thousands of
dollars to go to people
because they need money they really
despite the good numbers despite numbers
like that
they need money to live and i want that
to happen the democrats don't care about
that
they just want to give bailout money to
their friends running
big states poorly
do you want to give edward snowden a
pardon and bring him back you
you once suggested well i'm going to
look at it i mean i'm not that aware of
the snowden situation but i'm going to
start looking at it
there are many many people it seems to
be a split decision that many people
think that
he should be somehow treated differently
and other people think he did
very bad things and i'm going to take a
very good look at it okay
i mean i i've i've seen people that are
very conservative and very liberal and
they agree on the same issue they
agree both ways i'm going to take a look
at that very strongly edward snowden
yeah please
um do you agree with dr robert redfield
who um earlier this week said if america
doesn't follow public health guidelines
we could be in store for one of the
worst faults we've ever faced from a
public health perspective
no i mean you can't compare it to uh
1917 that was
incredible that was a that was the worst
ever by far that was you look at they
lost possibly 100 million people no i
don't agree with that but
if you look at these numbers they're
coming down very substantially and i do
believe that americans many are wearing
masks which is a good thing
uh again some people thought that you
shouldn't wear masks you know when this
whole thing started
dr fauci who i like and respect said
don't wear masks okay and so did dr
redfield
and then all of a sudden it was like
everybody should wear a mess and that's
okay
people can change their mind but wash
your hands good hygiene all of those
things
i think people are really doing it to a
level that they've never done before
and when you look and when you look at
when you look at the numbers
the way the numbers are coming out i
mean
it's very impressive when you see what's
happening by the way florida doing well
you see that and hospitalizations and
you know normally you
would have had a build more hot like we
did for the first surge
we've done it right we closed it up we
had the greatest economy in history
we closed it up we understand the
disease now nobody knew nobody knew what
was hitting us right nobody knew that
old people would be very very
susceptible especially if they have
heart and diabetes problems and other
problems that all people would be very
susceptible and young people would be
extremely good with it if you look at
the percentages they're a tiny
percentage that have
problems especially the big problem so
no i i think that we're doing very well
we're on our way and we're also opening
up our economy and our economy is going
to set records and if uh stupid people
aren't elected next year we're gonna
have one of the greatest years
that we've ever had
jennifer go ahead please thank you mr
president you've already taken action
on tick tock and wechat yeah which other
chinese tech companies are you looking
at
banning from operating in the united
states well the big thing is huawei
right
huawei's not here in huawei i'm not
allowing and i've told
european countries and others australia
has been fantastic as an example but
huawei's not coming here
and we told certain countries that were
thinking about huawei that's okay you
can use them but we're not going to be
sharing intelligence and
they've all backed away you look at the
uk it looked like they were going that
way and now they've backed out
scotland yard are there other particular
companies there are
most well yeah they're we're looking at
other things yes we are
we are right there say that you want the
mail to be processed
as quickly as it can but why is your
postal service dismantling these mail
sorting machines across the country at
the time
well you'll have to ask him i know this
he's a very efficient operator a very
good operator but again
he needs money to operate if you're
going to hit him with millions of
ballots and
if you ask him he will tell you and
he'll tell you very nicely
you have the money it's sitting there
it's ready to go the democrats don't
want to approve it
but i want ready for other things too i
want money to go to people
so they can live very nicely because
china caused the problem they didn't
mr president on the campaign
will you say now that kamala harris is
eligible
to run and be vice president or
president based on
be born in oakland california so i have
nothing to do with that i read
something about it and i will say that
he is a
brilliant lawyer that i guess he wrote
an article about it so i know nothing
about it but it's not something that
bothers me
but sir when you do that it creates why
do you say that i just don't know about
it but it's not something that we will
be pursuing
let me put it differently let me be let
me put it differently don't tell me what
i know
let me put it differently let me put it
differently
to me it doesn't bother me at all
i don't know about it i read one quick
article
the lawyer happens to be a brilliant
lawyer as you probably know
he wrote an article saying there could
be a problem it's not something that i'm
going to be pursuing
is she eligible i i just told you
i have not gone into it in great detail
if she's got a problem you would have
thought that she would have been vetted
you would have thought that she would
have been vetted by sleepy joe yeah go
ahead mr president sir i just want to
ask you after
three weeks of absolutely no deal you
have been bragging on democrats
constantly
why not come to the table personally and
sit with them i mean i know that speaker
pelosi
and minority were in the oval office in
december 2018. that did not go so well
everybody in the world saw that
why not invite them if they don't want
to come that's on them
so i think we've done very well we've
had uh three phases we're into phase
four we've gotten everything we wanted
and we've also gotten a great economy
all you have to do is take a look at
these charts our economy is doing good
but we want different things in them i
want money for the people
they want money to bail out democrat
governors
and democrat mayors listen to me listen
to me my people are doing very good and
my people call me they're in the office
they call me they call me when it's
right
nobody knows the deal better than i do
when it's right i'll meet
but right now it's not right they want a
trillion dollars to bail out badly run
states state their democrat they're all
i mean they're democrat states
will something happen possibly but i
want to tell you the country is doing
very well right now we can live very
happily with it without it
but i'd like to do it because i want to
give money to the people i want to put
money into the people's hands they want
to put money at the politicians hands
so that the politicians don't look
stupid
i've had some differences with your
defense secretary mark esper do you have
confidence in his leadership there
mark jesper did you call him jesper
oh okay some people call him yes no i
get along with him
i get along with him fine he's fine yeah
no problem i consider firing
everybody
at some point at some point that's what
happens jennifer do you have something
jennifer you're working so hard do you
think that
there will be anyone else who leaves
your cabinet after the election sir
so if we have
the success i think we have a silent
majority the likes of which has never
been seen before i think you read about
it
where 62 of the people say they're not
even telling the truth on polling
and where the polling is fake you know
where they do registered voters and
where they do
many more democrats than they do
republicans same has happened last time
but this year i think we have much more
enthusiasm maybe those people back there
would understand it better than anybody
but
i think there's more enthusiasm for 2020
than there was even for 2016
and 2016 was a record you found that out
and i believe there's much more
enthusiasm now than there was even
in 2016. we have a silent majority the
likes of which nobody has seen
i just look there are thousands of boats
in lakes rivers and oceans
thousands and thousands of boats
it's called boaters for trump voters for
trump pence
there's signs all over some of the boats
have ten flags on them they're
incredible
they're thousands we did nothing to do
this
this is just generic it just happened
let me just tell you i think the
level of enthusiasm for what we're doing
we want law and order
we want low taxes they want to raise
your taxes
they want to get rid of they want to
have open borders and they want to
defund the police how do you win on that
they want to go to texas and they want
to go to pennsylvania and they want to
stop fracking and
ohio they want to stop fracking they're
against steel
they're a guest against anything with
petroleum the word petroleum in it
you won't have a country these people
are crazy
[Music]
say go ahead as far as your cabinet goes
do you think you'll see more turnover in
your cabinet well i don't know i think
for next year i mean generally speaking
a lot of times i understand when
if we win a president will ask for the
resignation of everybody and then bring
back the people he wants that's happened
before steve
and i could see something like that
happening i think that makes sense no
i have a very good cabinet i mean with
few exceptions i wouldn't say i'm
thrilled with everybody frankly
but i have overall i think we have a
very good cabinet
i think this i will say this no
administration
none no administration first three and a
half years
has done anywhere near what we've done
300
we will have at the end of the first
term 300 maybe more
federal judges including court of
appeals two supreme court justices
nobody has done this if take a look at
take a look at what we've done
the biggest tax cuts in history biggest
regulation cuts in history rebuilt our
military
took care of our vets we have a 91
approval rating from the vets nobody's
ever had a 91
approval rating before we i guarded the
second amendment
they want to destroy the second
amendment take a look at kamala
they want to destroy the second
amendment and as you know joe is has no
control over anybody
he has no control over himself okay
thank you very much everybody
thank you